this video is sponsored by Air Hogs I've
never flown a drone using fpv before
this subscribe super cool how come I
haven't done this earlier whose fault is
that don't try to get me to say the word
good try them Sam will probably have his
own way of introducing this we were
sitting around coming up with ideas for
this video that we're about to shoot and
he's like why don't we play drone tag
sounds like something you should never
do at work which makes it the perfect
opportunity to do it here on the Sam and
Nico Channel okay so it's not just drone
tag it's not just like oh I can run away
but if you heard of the game called
Korean arm wrestling Korean wrestling
it's real easy
I check it out so the reason Korean
wrestling aren't simple I really I think
there's there could be another name for
this it might actually be called Korean
wrestling right that's my disclaimer
yeah so Korean wrestling the two people
stand roughly arm's reach okay and at
the beginning of the match the goal is
to get the other person to lose their
footing you cannot move your feet for
the duration of the game the only other
rule here is that the players can touch
nothing on the opponent's body except
the palms of their hands so we have to
be fighting like this see I can I can't
push them here I can't do anything so
that's all Sam is actually very good at
it's simple it's called Korean wrestling
[Music]
[Applause]
don't ever go far
[Music]
he doesn't focus on the hands he focuses
on your feet maybe I do know so we
should do this with drone can't move
your feet while you're playing drone tag
and you're trying to tag another person
with the drone and the first person to
either be hit by that drone or move from
their position loses first one to knock
off balance or hit another person with
the gern above the belt wins if someone
hits gets hit well just do a fast we
said keep going have to keep going
[Music]
[Applause]
we do as many points as you can gonna do
that again I think that looked pretty
well but for me I notice every time I
lined up on target it just hit the
throttle for it's very consistent gonna
change it up we'll try one vote we just
do drone tag in general so wonder own
trying to hit anyone they can everyone
is able to dodge to move anything it's
just a matter of if the drone touches
them if you get caught with the drone
you have to do 50 pushups of hot potato
drone whoever tags the most people
receives a Stevens buck notarized from
corridor digital I'm gonna hit someone
without even looking Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it's kind of low on juice no you
gotta tag somebody buddy no drone video
would be complete without actually
racing the drones so we took a bunch of
stuff from around our studio we set it
up and hallway
and we made a little impromptu race
course for you guys Joey
[Music]
we had a ton of fun with these air hugs
drones they're super durable they're fun
to fly and you can turn anything into a
racehorse
get your hands on some we'd love to see
what race courses you guys can come up
with post a video on our subreddit we'll
be checking it out and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]